The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
We continue our discussion
of quantum states of light.
We talked at length
about coherent state,
and when you talk about
quantum states of light,
each mode of the
electromagnetic field
is an harmonic oscillator.
We also encountered,
naturally, the number states.
And we realized--
yesterday, actually,
in the last class-- that
those number states have
non-classical properties.
For instance, they have a g2
function, the second order
correlation function,
which is smaller
than 1, which is impossible
for classic light,
as you're proving in one of
your homework assignment.
So at that point, we have
encountered coherent states,
which are as close as
possible to classical states.
And we have found the number
states as non-classical states.
Well, are there other
interesting states?
I wouldn't ask you this question
if the answer would not be yes,
and this is what we
want to discuss today.
We want to talk about
non-classical states of light,
which we can engineer,
actually, in the laboratory,
by sending laser light
through nonlinear crystals.
Those go by the name,
squeezed states.
Just to give you
the cartoon picture,
in our two-dimensional diagram,
with the quasi-probabilities,
we have coherent
states, where the area
of this disk, delta x
delta p, is h-bar over two.
It's uncertainty limited.
What we can do we now, is--
we cannot go beyond this.
This is the fundamental
limit of quantum physics.
However, we can take this
circle and we can squeeze it.
We can squeeze it
horizontally, we can squeeze it
into an elongated
vertical shape,
or we can squeeze
it at any angle.
That's what we call,
squeezed states.
And those states have
non-classical properties.
They are important
for metrology they
are important for teleportation.
There are lots and
lots of reasons
why you want to know about them.
But again, as so often, I
feel I cannot convey to you
the excitement of doing
squeezing in the quantum
domain.
And many, many
physicists now, they
hear about squeezing just
in the quantum domain.
But I want to start with
classical squeezing.
I will actually show you
video of an experiment
on classical squeezing.
You can see squeezing
with your own eyes.
But this is just sort
of to set the stage,
to also get a feel
of what squeezing is.
And then we'll do quantum
mechanical squeezing.
But maybe-- tongue
in cheek-- I would
say, since classical harmonic
oscillators and quantum
harmonic oscillators
have a lot in common,
the step from classical
squeezing to quantum
of mechanical squeezing
is actually rather small.
It's nice to squeeze light.
It's nice to have those
non-classical states.
But the question is,
how can you detect it?
If you can't detect it, you
can't take advantage of it.
And the detection has
to be face-coherent.
I will tell you what that is.
And it goes by the name,
homodyne detection.
And finally, we
can take everything
we have learned together, and
discuss how, in the laboratory,
teleportation of a
quantum state is done.
There is a nice
teleportation scheme,
and I want to use
that as an example
that the language and the
concepts I've introduced
are useful.
Concepts like,
squeezing operator,
displacement operator--
those methods
allowing us to, in
a very clear way,
discuss schemes which
lead to teleportation.
That's the menu for today.
Let's start with
classical squeezing.
For squeezing, we need
an harmonic oscillator,
means for parabolic potential,
we have potential v of x.
And then we study
the motion of-- that
should be x squared-- the
motion of a particle in there.
Before I even get
started any equation,
let me explain what the effect
of squeezing will be about.
If you have an
harmonic oscillator,
you have, actually, the
motion of a pendulum.
It has two quadrature
components, the cosine motion
and the sine motion.
And they are 90
degrees out of phase.
What happens now is,
if you parametrically
drive the harmonic
oscillator-- you modulate
the harmonic oscillator
potential-- it's to omega.
I will show you mathematically,
it's very, very easy to show,
that depending on the
phase of the drive,
you will actually exponentially
amplify the sine motion,
and exponentially damp
the cosine motion.
Or if you change, vice versa.
So by driving the system, you
can amplify one quadrature
component, and exponentially
die out the other quadrature
component.
And that is called,
classical squeezing.
Let's do the math.
It's very simple.
Our equation of motion
has the two solutions
I've just mentioned.
It has a solution
with cosine omega 0,
and one with sine omega 0 t.
And we have two coefficients.
The cosine is called, c.
The sine coefficient
is called, s.
I have to call it c 0, because
I want to call that c and s.
So what we have here is, we have
the two quadrature components
of the motion in an
harmonic oscillator.
And graphically, we need that
for the electromagnetic field,
as well.
When we have our two
axes, like, you know,
the complex plane for the
cosine of probabilities,
I call one the s-axis.
One is the c-axis.
That's just something
which confuses me.
If you have only one--
just give me one second.
Cosine-- Yeah.
If you have only cosine
motion, the s component is 0,
and the harmonic oscillator
would just oscillate here.
If you have only
a sine component,
you stay on the x-axis.
And now, if you have an equal
amount of cosine and sine,
then you can describe the
trajectory to go in a circle.
OK.
This is just the undriven
harmonic oscillator.
I don't want to dwell
on it any longer.
But what we are
doing now is, we are
adding a small parametric drive.
Parametric drive means we
modulate the spring constant,
or we replace the original
harmonic potential,
which was this, by an
extra modulation term.
So we have a small
parameter, epsilon.
And as I pointed
out, the modulation
is at twice the
resonance frequency.
Now we want to solve
the equation of motion
for the harmonic oscillator,
using this added potential.
The way how we want to solve
it is, we assume epsilon
is very small.
So if the pendulum is
swinging with cosine omega t,
it will take a while
for the epsilon
term-- for the small term--
to change the motion.
So therefore, we assume
that we can actually
go back and use our
original solution.
And assume that
over a short term,
the epsilon term is
not doing anything.
So for a short time, it looks
like an harmonic oscillator
with a sine omega 0, and
cosine omega 0 t oscillation.
But over any longer
period of time,
the small term will
have an effect.
And therefore, the
coefficients c of t, c, and s
are no longer constant, but
change as a function of time.
We want to solve, now,
the equation of motion.
That means we use this,
here, as our ansatz.
And we calculate the
second derivative.
We assume that the coefficients
c and s are changing slowly.
Therefore, the second derivative
of c and s can be neglected.
By taking the derivative
of the second derivative
of the cosine term
and the sine term,
of course we simply get,
minus omega 0 squared, x of t.
And now we have the
second-order derivatives.
Since we neglect the
second-order derivative of c
and s, the other
terms we get when
we take the second derivative
is, first derivative
of c times first
derivative of cosine.
First derivative of s times
first derivative of sine.
So we get two more terms,
which are, minus omega 0 c dot,
times sine omega 0 t.
Plus omega 0 s dot,
times cosine omega 0 t.
This is the second derivative
of our ansatz for x.
This has to be equal
to the force provided
by the potential.
So taking the potential--
We need, now, the
derivative of the potential,
for the potential of
use across this line.
The first part is the
unperturbed harmonic
oscillator, which
gives us simply,
omega 0 squared times x.
And the second term, due to
the parametric drive, is 2
sine omega 0 t.
And now, for x,
we use our ansatz
for x, which is the
slowly-changing amplitude c
times cosine omega 0 t,
plus s times sine omega 0 t.
Those two terms cancel out.
So now we have products
of trig function.
Sine 2 omega times cosine omega.
Well, you know if you take the
product of two trig functions,
it becomes a trig function
of the sum or the difference
of the argument.
So if you take sine 2 omega
0 times cosine omega 0,
and we use trigonometric
identities,
we get an oscillation at 3
omega 0, which is 2 plus 1.
And one at the difference,
which is omega 0.
Let me write down the terms
which are of interest to us.
Namely, the ones at omega 0.
So let me factor out epsilon
omega 0 squared over 2.
Then we have the term c times
sine omega 0 t, plus s times
cosine.
And then we have
terms at 3 omega
0, which we are
going to neglect.
Now we compare the two
sides of the equations.
We have sine omega 0 term.
We have cosine omega 0 term.
And the two sides
of the equations
are only consistent if the two
coefficients of the sine term,
and the sine term, are the same.
So therefore, we
obtain two equations.
One for c dot, one for s dot.
And these are first-order
differential equations.
The solution is
clearly an exponential.
But one has a plus sign,
one has a minus sign.
So the c component, the
c quadrature component,
is exponentially amplified
with this time constant.
Whereas the sine component is
exponentially de-amplified.
This finishes the
mathematical discussion
of classical squeezing.
We find that s of t, and c of
t, are exponential functions.
In one case, it's
exponentially increasing.
In the other case, it is
exponentially decreasing.
And that means that, well,
if we go to our diagram,
here-- and let's assume
we had an arbitrary
superposition of cosine
and sine amplitude.
This is cosine.
This is sine.
We had sort of a
cosine oscillation,
and a sine oscillation.
Which means that, as
a phasor, the system
was moving on an ellipse.
If the sine component is
exponentially de-amplified,
and the cosine component
is exponentially amplified,
that means whatever we start
with is squashed horizontally,
is squashed vertically.
And is amplified horizontally.
In the end, it will
become a narrow strip.
So this is classical squeezing.
You may want to ask, why did
I neglect the 3 omega 0 term.
Well, I have to, otherwise
I don't have a solution.
Because I have to be consistent
with my approximations.
So what I did here
is, I had an equation
where I have the clear
vision that the solution has
a slowly varying c
and s coefficient.
And then I simply use that.
I take the second-order
derivative,
and I have only
Fourier components
with omega 0, the
sine, and cosine.
Now I've made an
approximation, here.
For the derivative
of the potential,
the first line is exact.
But in order to match
the approximation
I've done on the
other side, I can only
focus on two Fourier components
resonant with omega 0,
which I have here.
So in other words,
the 3 omega 0 term
would lead to additional
accelerations.
Which I have not included
in the treatment.
So it's consistent
with the ansatz.
It's consistent
with the assumption
that we have
resonant oscillations
with a slowly
changing amplitude.
There will be a small
[INAUDIBLE] for your omega 0,
but it will be small.
Any questions about that?
Let me then show you
an animation of that.
Classroom files.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-We have Dave Pritchard,
professor of physics at MIT,
demonstrating what squeezing is.
Right now, we see a wave that's
going around in a circle.
What's next?
What's going to happen
now, Professor Pritchard?
-Well, if we drive it in
twice the basic period,
then we will parametrically
amplify one quadrature
component, and we will
un-amplify the other one.
So now I'm going to
start doing that.
And then you notice that its
motion turns into an ellipse.
We've amplified this
quadrature component,
but we've un-amplifed that one.
And that's squeezing.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Feel free
to try it at home.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Actually,
you may start
to think about
this demonstration.
What he has shown was, when you
have a circular pendulum which
goes in a circle or
an ellipse, and you
start pulling on the rope
with a certain phase,
that one quadrature component
will be de-amplified.
The other one will be amplified.
And as a result, no
matter what the circular
or the elliptical motion was,
after driving it for a while,
it will only swing
in one direction.
And this is the collection
you have amplified.
There is one thing which
should give you pause.
I have discussed, actually,
a single harmonic oscillator.
What Dave Pritchard
demonstrated was actually
two harmonic oscillators.
The harmonic oscillator has
an x motion and a y motion.
However, you can
say, this was just
sort of a trick for
the demonstration,
because when you have
a circular motion,
initially, you
have the sine omega
and the cosine omega 0 component
present simultaneously.
And you can see what
happens to the sine
and the cosine component
in one experiment.
So in that sense, he did
two experiments at once.
He showed what happens
when you have, initially,
a sine component, and what
happens when you initially
have a cosine component.
OK.
So we know what
classical squeezing is.
And what we have learned, also--
and this helps me now a lot
to motivate how we squeeze
in quantum mechanics--
you have realized that what
is really essential here is,
to drive it to omega 0.
What we need now to do
squeezing in the quantum domain,
if we want to squeeze light,
we need something at 2 omega 0.
So let's now squeeze
quantum mechanically.
Go back here.
The second sub-section is
now, squeezed quantum states.
What we want to
discuss is, we want
to discuss a quantum
harmonic oscillator.
We want to have some form of
parametric drive at 2 omega 0.
And this will result
in squeezed states.
Now, what does it require, if
you want to bring in 2 omega 0?
Well, let's not forget
our harmonic oscillators
are modes of the
electromagnetic field.
If you now want to couple a mode
of the electromagnetic field,
at 2 omega 0, with our
harmonic oscillator at omega 0,
we need a coupling between
two electromagnetic fields.
So therefore, we need nonlinear
interactions between photons.
So this was a tautology.
We need nonlinear
physics, which leads
to interactions between photons.
Linear physics means,
each harmonic oscillator
is independent.
So we need some
nonlinear process
six which will be equivalent
to have interactions
between photons.
The device which we
will provide that
is an optical
parametric oscillator.
I could spend a long
time explaining to you
how those nonlinear
crystals work.
What is the polarization,
what is the polarizability,
how do you drive it,
what is the nonlinearity.
But for the discussion
in this class,
which focuses on
fundamental concepts,
I can actually bypass
it by just saying,
assume you have a system--
and this is actually
what the optical
parametric oscillator does,
is you pump it with
photons at 2 omega 0.
And then the crystal generates
two photons at omega 0.
Which of course, is consistent
with energy conservation.
And if you fulfill some
phase-matching condition,
it's also consistent with
momentum conservation.
But I don't want to go into
phase-matching at this point.
Technically, this is
done as simple as that.
You have to pick
the right crystal.
Actually, a crystal which does
mixing between three photon
fields cannot have
inversion symmetry,
otherwise this
nonlinear term is 0.
What you need is
a special crystal.
KDP is a common choice.
And this crystal will now
do for us the following.
You shine in laser light.
Let's say, at 532
nanometer, a green light.
And then this photon breaks up
into two photons of omega 0.
This is how it's done
in the laboratory.
The piece of art is, you have
to pick the right crystal.
It has to be cut
at the right angle.
You may have to heat
it, and make sure
that you select the
temperature for which
some form of resonant condition
is fulfilled, to do that.
But in essence,
that's what you do.
One laser beam, put in a
crystal, and then the photon
is broken into two equal parts.
And these are our two
photons at omega 0.
OK.
I hope you enjoy the
elegance-- we can completely
bypass all the material physics
by putting operators on it.
We call this mode, b.
And we call this mode, a.
So the whole parametric process,
the down conversion process
of one photon into
two, is now described
by the following Hamiltonian.
We destroy a photon in
mode b, a 2 omega 0.
And now we create
two photons at omega.
We destroy a photon
at 2 omega 0,
create two photons at omega 0.
And since the Hamiltonian
has to be Hamiltonian,
the opposite, the
time-reverse process,
has to be possible, too.
And that means we destroy
two photons at omega 0,
and create one
photon at 2 omega 0.
So now we forget about
nonlinear crystals,
about non-inversion
symmetry in materials.
We just take this
Hamiltonian and play with it.
By simply looking
at the Hamiltonian,
what is the time
evolution of a photon
field under this Hamiltonian.
We figure out what happens
when you send light
through a crystal, and
what is the output.
And I want to show you now
that the output of that
is squeezed light, which is
exactly what I promised you
with these quasi-probabilities.
We have a coherent state,
which is a nice circle.
We time-evolve the coherent
state, our nice round circle,
with this Hamiltonian.
And what we get is an ellipse.
And if you want intuition,
look at the classical example
we did before, which
really tells you
in a more intuitive
way what is happening.
OK.
We want to make one
simplifying assumption, here.
And this is that
we pump the crystal
at 2 omega 0 with a
strong laser beam.
So we assume that the mode,
b, is a powerful laser beam.
Or in other words, a
strong coherent state.
We assume that the mode,
b, is in a coherent state.
Coherent states
are always labeled
with a complex parameter,
which I call beta, now.
Well, it's mode b,
therefore I call it, beta.
For mode a, I've
called it, alpha.
The coherent state has an
amplitude, which I call,
r over 2.
And it has a phase.
We know, of course, that the
operator, b, acting on beta,
gives us beta times beta,
because a coherent state is
an eigenstate of the
annihilation operator.
But when we look at the
action of the operator b
plus, the photon
creation operator,
the coherent state
is not an eigenstate
of the creation operator.
It's only an eigenstate of
the annihilation operator.
But what sort of happens
is, the coherent state
is the sum over many,
many number states with n.
And the creation operator
goes from n, to n plus 1,
and has matrix elements which
are square root n plus 1.
So in other words,
if n is large,
and if we don't care about the
subtle difference between n,
and n plus 1, in this
limit the coherent state
is also an eigenstate of
the creation operator,
with an eigenvalue,
which is beta star.
This means that we have a
coherent state which is strong.
Strong means, it has
a large amplitude
of the electric field.
The photon states which
are involved, n, are large.
And we don't have whether
it be n, or n plus 1.
This is actually, also,
I should mention it here,
explicitly-- this is
sort of the step when
we have a quantum
description of light.
And we replace the operators,
p and p dega, by a c number,
then we really go back
to classical physics.
Then we pretend that we have a
classical electric field, which
is described by the
imaginary part of beta.
So when you have an Hamiltonian,
where you write down
an electric field, and
the electric field is not
changing-- you have an
external electric field.
This is really the limit
of a quantum field,
where you've eliminated
the operator by a c number.
This is essentially
your electric field.
And we do this
approximation, here.
Because we are interested in
the quantum features of mode
a-- a is our quantum
mode, with single photons,
or with a vacuum state,
and we want to squeeze it.
b is just, they have
parametric drive.
With this approximation, we
have only the a operators.
This is our operator.
Any question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] would
give us a [INAUDIBLE], right?
PROFESSOR: Yes, thank you.
That means, here should
be a minus sign, yes.
OK.
I've motivated our discussion
with this nonlinear crystal,
which generates pair of photons.
This is the Hamiltonian
which describes it.
And if you want to have a time
evolution by this Hamiltonian,
you put this Hamiltonian into
a time evolution operator.
In other words, you--
e to the minus iHt
is the time evolution.
If you now evolve a quantum
state of light for a fixed
time, t, we apply the
operator, e to the minus iHt,
to the quantum state of light.
What I've just said
is now the motivation
for the definition of
the squeezing operator.
The squeezing
operator, S of r, is
defined to be the exponent
of minus r over 2,
a squared minus a dega squared.
This is related to
the discussion above.
You would say, hey, you want
to do that time evolution,
where is the i?
Well, I've just made
a choice of phi.
If phi is chosen
to be pi over 2,
then the time evolution
with the Hamiltonian,
above, gives me the
squeezing operator, below.
So with that motivation
we are now studying,
what is the squeezing
operator doing
to quantum states of light?
Any questions about that?
I know I spent a
lot of time on it.
I could have taught this
class by just saying, here
is an operator, the
squeezing operator.
Trust me, it does
wonderful things.
And then we can
work out everything.
But I find his
unsatisfying, so I
wanted to show you what is
really behind this operator.
And I want you to
have a feeling,
where does this operator come
from, and what is it doing?
In essence, what I've
introduced into our description
is now an operator, which
is creating and destroying
pairs of photons.
And this will actually
do wonderful things
to our quantum states.
What are the properties
of the squeezing operator?
What is important
is, it is unitary.
It does a unitary
time evolution.
You may not see
that immediately, so
let me explain that.
You know from your basic
quantum mechanics course,
that e to the i operator A is
unitary, when A is Hermitian.
So the squeezing operator--
with the definition
above-- can be written
as, I factor out
2 i's over 2 a squared
minus a dega squared.
And you can immediately
verify that this part, here,
is Hermitian.
If you do the
Hermitian conjugate,
a squared turns
into a dega squared.
a dega squared turns
into a squared.
So we have a problem
with a minus sign.
But if you do the
complex conjugate of i,
this takes care
of the minus sign.
So this part is Hermitian.
We multiply it with i,
therefore this whole operator.
Thus a unitary transformation
in [INAUDIBLE].
Any questions?
OK.
So after being familiar with
this operator, we want to know,
what is this operator doing?
I can describe, now, what this
operator does, in a Schrodinger
picture, or in a
Heisenberg picture.
I pick whatever is
more convenient.
And for now, this is
the Heisenberg picture.
In the Heisenberg picture, what
is changing are the operators.
Therefore, in the
Heisenberg picture,
this unitary transformation
transforms the operators.
And we can study what happens
when we transform the operator,
x.
The unitary transformation
is done by-- the operator, x,
is transformed by multiplying
from the left side
with S, from the righthand
side with S dega.
You are familiar with
expressions like, this,
and how to disentangle them.
If you have an e to
the i alpha, e to
the minus alpha, if you
could move the alpha past x.
So if A and x commute,
i A, minus i A
would just give unity.
So therefore, this
expression is just
x, unless you have non-Hermitian
commutators between A and x.
I think you have solved, in
your basic mechanics course,
many such problems which
involve identities of that form.
Then there are higher
order commutator,
the commutator of A with
the commutator of a x.
Unless one of those
commutator vanishes,
you can get an infinite series.
Our operator, A, is nothing else
than the annihilation operator,
a squared minus the creation
operator, a dega squared.
So we can express everything
in terms of a, and a dega.
The position operator in
our harmonic oscillator
can also be expressed
by a, and a dega.
By doing elementary
manipulations
on the righthand side,
and recouping terms,
you find immediately that
the unitary transformation
of the Heisenberg operator, x,
gives you an x operator back.
But multiplied with an
exponential, e to the r.
And if we would do the same to
the momentum operator, which
is a minus a dega
over square root 2,
we will find that the unitary
transformation of the momentum
operator is de-amplifying
the momentum
operator by an
exponential factor.
If we would assume
that we have a vacuum
state in the
harmonic oscillator,
and while classically, it
would be at x equals 0,
p equals 0, quantum
mechanically,
we have single-point noise in
x, and single-point noise in p.
Then you would find that
the squeezing operator is
amplifying the
quantum noise in x.
But it squeezes, or
reduces, the noise in p.
If we apply this squeezing
operator to the vacuum state,
we obtain what is usually
called, squeezed vacuum.
And it means that, in this
quasi-probability diagram,
the action of the
squeezing operator
is turning the vacuum
state into an ellipse.
What happens to energy, here?
The vacuum state is the
lowest-energy state.
If you now act with a
squeezing operator to it,
we obtain a state which
has-- the same energy?
Is it energy-conserving,
or very high energy?
AUDIENCE: Higher [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Why?
AUDIENCE: It's no
longer the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sure, yeah.
It's a vacuum state.
We act on the
vacuum state, but we
get a state which is no
longer the vacuum state.
The reason why we
have extra energy--
the squeezed vacuum is
very, very energetic.
Because the squeezing operator
had a dega squared, a squared.
Well a squared, the annihilation
operator acting on the vacuum,
gives 0.
But what we are creating now,
we are acting on the vacuum,
and we are creating
pairs of photons.
So we are adding, literally,
energy to the system.
And the energy, of course,
comes from the drive laser,
from the laser 2 omega 0, which
delivers the energy in forms
of photons which
are split into half,
and they go into
our quantum field.
In the limit of
infinite squeezing--
I will show it to
you, mathematically,
but it's nice to
discuss it already here.
In the limit of
infinite squeezing,
what is the state
we are getting?
AUDIENCE: Eigenstate
of momentum.
PROFESSOR: Eigenstate momentum.
We get the p equals
0 eigenstate.
What is the energy of the
p equals 0 eigenstate?
AUDIENCE: Infinite.
It has to contain
all number states.
PROFESSOR: It contains
all number states?
OK, you think immediately into
number states, which is great.
But in a more
pedestrian way, the p
equals 0 state has
no kinetic energy.
But if a state is localized
in momentum, p equals 0,
it has to be infinitely
smeared out on the x-axis.
And don't forget, we have an
harmonic oscillator potential.
If you have a particle which
is completely delocalized in x,
it has infinite potential
energy at the wings.
So therefore in the limit
of extreme squeezing,
we involve an extreme
number of number states.
Actually, I want to be more
specific-- of photon pairs.
We have states with 2n, and
n can be infinitely large.
But we'll see in the classical
picture, what we get here
when we squeeze it is,
we get the p equals
0 eigenstate, which has infinite
energy, due to the harmonic
oscillator potential.
If we would allow
with the system
now, after we have squeezed
it, to evolve for a quarter
period in the
harmonic oscillator,
then the ellipse would turn
into an vertical ellipse.
So this is now an
eigenstate of x.
It's the x equals 0 eigenstate.
But the x equals 0 eigenstate
has also infinite energy,
because due to Heisenberg's
uncertainty relation,
it involves momentum states
of infinite momentum.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] a is
the photon field, right?
So p is roughly the
electrical field, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So it's kind of that
the electric field counts 0,
and x is kind of the a,
the-- and it-- because of
[INAUDIBLE].
The electrical
field is squeezed?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It means we
have no electrical field?
PROFESSOR: We'll come
to that in a moment.
I want to do a little bit
more math, to show you.
I wanted to derive for you
an expression of the squeeze
state, in number
basis, and such.
Your question
mentioned something
which is absolutely correct.
By squeezing that, we
have now the p-axis
is the electric field axis.
So now we have, actually, in
the limit of infinite squeezing,
we have an electric field which
has no uncertainty anymore.
By squeezing the coherent state
into a momentum eigenstate,
we have created a sharp
value for the electric field.
We have created an
electric field eigenstate.
Well you would say,
it's pretty boring,
because the only electric
field state we have created
is electric field e equals 0.
But in the next
half-hour, we want
to discuss the
displacement operator,
and I will tell you what it is.
That we can now
move the ellipses,
and move the circles,
anywhere where we want.
So once we have
an electric field
state which has a sharp value
of the electric field at e
equals 0, we can
just translate it.
But before you get too
excited about having
an eigenstate of
the electric field,
I want you to think
about what happened
after one quarter-period it
of the harmonic oscillator
frequency.
It turns upside down,
and your electric field
has an infinite variance.
That's what quantum
mechanics tells us.
We can create
electric fields which
are very precise, but
only for a short moment.
So in other words, this
electric field state
which we have created
would have a sharp value.
A moment later, it would
be very smeared out,
then it has a sharp
value again, and then
it's smeared out again.
I mean, that's what
squeezed states are.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: That's
why [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's why we
need homodyne detection.
Yes, exactly.
If we have squeezed something,
which is sort of narrow,
that's great for measurement.
Now we can do a
measurement of, maybe,
a LIGO measurement for
gravitational waves with higher
precision, because
we have a more
precise value in
our quantum state.
But we have to look at
it at the right time.
We have to look
at it synchronized
with the harmonic motion.
Homodyne detection means we
look only at the sine component,
or at the cosine component.
Or if I want to simplify
it, what you want to do
is, if you have a
state like this,
you want to measure the
electric field, so to speak,
stroboscopically.
You want to look at
your system always when
the ellipse is like this.
The stroboscopic measurement
is, as I will show you,
in essence, a
lock-in measurement,
which is phase-sensitive.
And this will be
homodyne detection.
So we can only take
advantage of the squeezing,
of having less uncertainty
in one quadrature component,
if you do phase-sensitive
detection, which
is homodyne detection.
But now I'm already an
hour ahead of the course.
OK.
Back to basics.
We want to explicitly
calculate, now,
how does a squeezed
vacuum look like.
We actually want to do it
twice, because it's useful.
We have to see it in
two different basis.
One is, I want to write down
the squeezed vacuum for you
in a number representation.
And then in a coherent
state representation.
The squeezing operator is an
exponential function involving
a squared, and a dega squared.
And of course, we're now using
the Taylor expansion of that.
We are acting on
the vacuum state.
I will not do the calculation.
It's again, elementary.
You have n factorial, you have
terms with a dega acts on c,
well, you pay 2 photons.
If it acts again, it
adds 2 more photons,
and the matrix element
of a dega acting on n
is square root n plus 1.
You just sort of
rearrange the terms.
And what you find is,
what I will write you down
in the next line.
The important thing you
should immediately realize
is, the squeeze state is
something very special.
It is the superposition
of number states,
but all number states are even
because our squeezing operator
creates pairs of photons.
This is what the parametric
down-conversion does.
We inject photons
into the vacuum,
but always exactly in pairs.
And therefore, it's
not a random state.
It's a highly correlated state
with very special properties.
OK.
If you do the calculation
and recoup the terms,
you get factorials,
you get 2 to the n,
you get another factorial.
You get hyperbolic tangent--
sorry, to the power n.
And the normalization is done
by the square root of the cos
function.
And the more we
squeeze, the larger
are the amplitudes at
higher and higher n.
But this is also obvious from
the graphic representation
I've shown you.
Let me add the coherent
state representation.
The coherence states are
related to the number
states in that way.
If we transform now from number
states to coherent states,
the straightforward
calculation gives, now,
superposition over
coherent states.
Coherent states
require an integral.
e to the minus e to the
r over 2, divided by--
Anyway, all this
expressions, they
may not be in its general
form, too illuminating.
But those things can
be done analytically.
I just want to mention the
interesting limiting case
of infinite squeezing.
AUDIENCE: When you do
the integral over alpha,
is this over like, a
magnitude of alpha,
or a real part, or [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I
remember, but I'm not
100% sure that
alpha is real, here.
I mean, it sort of
makes sense, because we
start with the vacuum state.
And if we squeeze
it, we are not really
going into the
imaginary direction.
So I think what is involved
here are only real alpha.
AUDIENCE: For negative r,
we should get [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: For negative r,
we need imaginary state.
AUDIENCE: So we
should [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Let me double-check.
I don't remember that.
You know that,
sometimes, I admit
it, the issue-- if
you research material,
prepare a course some years
ago, you forget certain things.
If I prepared the lecture,
and everything worked out
yesterday, I would know that.
But certain things
you don't remember.
As far as I know,
it's the real axis.
But I have to double-check.
The limiting case
is interesting.
If r goes to infinity, you
can show that this is simply
the integral, d alpha
over coherent states.
We have discussed,
graphically, the situation
where we had-- so these
are quasi-probabilities.
In that case of
infinite squeezing,
we have the momentum
eigenstate, p equals 0.
This is the limit of the
infinitely squeezed vacuum,
and in a coherent
state representation,
it is the integral over
coherent state alpha.
I'm pretty sure alpha is
real here, seeing that now.
There is a second limit, which
happens simply-- you can say,
by rotation, or by time
evolution-- which is the x
equals 0 eigenstate.
And this is proportional
to the integral over alpha
when we take the
coherent state i alpha,
and we integrate from
minus to plus infinity.
OK.
So we have connected
our squeezed states,
the squeezed vacuum, with number
states, with coherent states.
Now we need one more thing.
So far we've only
squeezed the vacuum,
and we have defined
the squeezing operator
that it takes a vacuum
state and elongates it.
In order to generate
more general states,
we want to get away
from the origin.
And this is done by the
displacement operator.
The definition of the
displacement operator
is given here.
The displacement by
a complex number,
alpha, is done by putting
alpha, and alpha star,
into an exponential function.
In many quantum
mechanic courses,
you show very easily the
elementary properties.
If the displacement
operator is used
to transform the annihilation
operator, it just does that.
If you take the complex
conjugate of it--
so in other words,
what that means is,
it's called the
displacement operator,
I just take that
as the definition.
But you immediately
see why it's called
the displacement
operator when we
do the unitary transformation
of the annihilation operator,
we get the annihilation operator
displaced by a complex number.
So the action,
the transformation
of the annihilation operator
is the annihilator operator
itself, minus a c number.
So therefore, we say, the
annihilation operator data
has been displaced.
So this is the action of
the displacement operator
on an operator-- on the
annihilation operator.
The question is now, how does
the displacement operator
act on quantum states?
And the simplest quantum
state we want to test out
is the vacuum state.
And well, not surprisingly,
the displacement operator,
displacing the vector
state by alpha,
is creating the
coherent state, alpha.
This can be proven in one line.
We take our displaced
vacuum, and we act on it
with the annihilation operator.
If we act with the annihilation
operator on something,
and we get the same thing
back times an eigenvalue,
we know it's a coherent state.
Because this was the
definition of coherent states.
So therefore, in order to show
that this is a coherent state,
we want to show that it's an
eigenstate of the annihilation
operator.
So this is what we want to do.
The proof is very easy.
By multiplying this expression
with unity, which is DD dega,
we have this.
And now we can use the
result for the transformation
of operators.
Namely, that this is simply
the annihilation operator,
plus alpha.
If the annihilation operator
acts on the vacuum state,
we get 0.
If alpha acts on the vacuum
state, we get alpha times 0.
So therefore, what
we obtain is that.
When the annihilation
operator acts on this state,
we get alpha times the state,
and therefore the state
is a coherent state
with eigenvalue alpha.
In a graphical way, if
you have a vacuum state
the displacement operator, D
alpha, takes a vacuum state
and creates a
coherent state alpha.
If you want to have squeezed
states with a finite value,
well, we just discussed
the electric field.
Related to the
harmonic oscillator,
we want squeeze
states, which are not
centered at the origin, which
have a finite value of x or p.
We can now create them by
first squeezing the vacuum,
and then displacing the state.
AUDIENCE: What's the
physical realization
of the displacement operator?
PROFESSOR: What is the
physical realization
of the displacement operator?
Just one second.
The physical representation
of the displacement operator--
we'll do that on Monday--
is the following.
If you pass an arbitrary state
through a beam splitter--
but it's a beam splitter
which has very, very
high transmission-- and then,
from the-- I'll just show that.
If you have a state-- this
is a beam splitter-- which
has a very high transmission,
T is approximately 1,
then the state passes through.
But then from the other
side of the beam splitter,
you come with a very
strong coherent state.
You have a coherent state
which is characterized
by a large complex number, beta.
And then there is a
reflection coefficient,
r, which is very small.
It sort of reflects the coherent
state with an amplitude r beta.
If you mix together the
transmitted state and r
beta-- I will show
that to you explicitly,
by doing a quantum treatment
of the beam splitter--
what you get is,
the initial state
is pretty much transmitted
without attenuation.
But the reflected part of
the strong coherent state--
you compensate for the
small r by a large beta--
does actually an exact
displacement of r beta.
It's actually great.
The beam splitter is
a wonderful device.
You think you have a
displacement operator
formulated with a's
and a dega's, it
looks like something extract.
But you can go to the lab,
simply get one beam splitter,
take a strong laser
beam, and whatever
you send through
the beam splitter
gets displaced, gets acted
upon by the beam splitter.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You showed the
displacement operator, when
you acted on the vacuum state,
will displace the vacuum
state to a state alpha.
Does it still hold
if you acted on,
like another coherent state.
Or in this case, a
squeeze state like that?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I haven't shown it,
but it's really--
it displaces-- When we
use this representation
with quasi-probabilities,
it simply
does a displacement
in the plane.
But no.
To be honest, when I say it does
a displacement on the plane,
it reminds me that we
have three different ways
of defining quasi-probabilities.
The w, the p, and
the q representation.
I know we use it all the
time, that we displace things
in the plane.
But I'm wondering if the
displacement operator does
an exact displacement of
all representations, or only
of the q representation.
That's something I
don't know for sure.
AUDIENCE: I was thinking it
could also, like-- I mean,
are you going to be able to
displace all types of light,
like thermal light, or any
representation of light
that you could put in, is the
same displacement operator
going to work?
Or is its domain just the
vacuum and coherent states?
PROFESSOR: The fact is,
the coherent states--
I've shown you that
it's a vacuum state.
I know that's the next thing to
show, the displacement operator
if you have a displacement
by alpha followed
by displacement by beta,
it is equal to displacement
by alpha plus beta.
So displacement
operator forms a group,
and if you do two
displacements, they
equal into one area
of displacement,
which is the sum of
two complex numbers.
What I'm just saying, if you
do the first displacement
you can get an arbitrarily
coherent state.
So therefore, the
displacement operator
is exactly displacing
a coherent state
by the argument of the
displacement operator.
And now if you take an
arbitrary quantum state
and expand it into coherent
states-- coherent states are
not only complete,
they are over-complete.
All you have done is,
you've done a displacement.
Now the over-completeness,
of course,
means you have to
think about it,
because you can represent
states in more than one way
by coherent states.
But if you have
your representation,
you just displace
it, and this is
the result of the
displacement operator.
So since the q
representation is simply,
you take the
statistical operator
and look for the
elements in alpha,
and if you displace alpha,
the q representation
has been moved around.
So I'm sure that for
the q representation,
for the q quasi-probabilities,
the displacement operator
shifted around in this place.
For the w and p
representation, I'm not sure.
Maybe there's an
expert in the audience
who knows more
about it than I do.
OK.
We have just five minutes left.
I want to discuss now
the electric field
of squeezed states.
And for that, let
me load a picture.
Insert picture.
Classroom files.
Let us discuss, now, the
electric field of squeezed
states.
Just as a reminder, we can
discuss the electric field
by using the quasi-probability
representation.
And the electric field
is the projection
of the quasi-probabilities
on the vertical axis.
And then the time evolution
is, that everything rotates
with omega in this
complex plane.
We discussed it already.
For coherent state, we have
a circle which rotates.
Therefore, the projected
fuzziness of the electric field
is always the same.
And as time goes by, we have
a sinusoidal-bearing electric
field.
Let me just make one comment.
If you look into the literature,
some people actually say,
the electric field
is the projection
on the horizontal axis.
So there are people who say,
the electric field is given
by the x-coordinate of
the harmonic oscillator,
whereas I'm telling you,
it's the p-coordinate.
Well, if you think
one person is wrong,
I would suggest you just
wait a quarter-period
of the harmonic oscillator, and
then the other person is right.
It's really just a
phase convention.
What do you assume
to be t equals
0-- it's really arbitrary.
But here in this course,
I will use the projections
on the vertical axis.
OK.
If you project the number
state, we get always,
0 electric field, with
a large uncertainty.
So that's just a reminder.
But now we have
a squeezed state.
It's a displaced squeezed state.
If you project it
onto the y-axis,
we have first some
large uncertainty.
I think this plot assumes that
we rotate with negative time,
so I apologize for that.
You can just invert
time, if you want.
So after a quarter-period,
the ellipse is now horizontal,
and that means the electric
field is very sharp.
As time goes by, you
see that the uncertainty
of the electric field
is large, small, large,
small-- it modulates.
It can become very extreme,
when you do extreme squeezing,
so you have an extremely precise
value of the electric field,
here, but you've a large
uncertainty, there.
Sometimes you want
to accurately measure
the 0 crossing of
the electric field.
This may be something
which interests you,
for an experiment.
In that case, you
actually want to have
an ellipse which is
horizontally squeezed.
Now, whenever the
electric field is 0,
there is very little noise.
But after a quarter-period,
when the electric field
reaches its maximum,
you have a lot of noise.
So it's sort of your choice
which way you squeeze.
Whether you want the
electric field to be precise,
have little fluctuations
when it goes through 0,
or when it goes
through the maximum.
So what we have done
here is, we have first
created the squeezed
vacuum, and then we
have acted on it with a
displacement operator.
OK.
I think that's a
good moment to stop.
Let me just say what I wanted
to take from this picture.
The fact that the electric
field is precise only
at certain moments means that
we can only take advantage of it
when we do a
phase-sensitive detection.
We only want to
sort of, measure,
the electric field
when it's sharp.
Or-- this is equivalent-- we
should regard light is always
composed of two
quadrature components.
You can say, the cosine,
the sine oscillation, the x,
and the p.
And the squeezing is
squeezed in one quadrature,
by it is elongated in
the other quadrature.
Therefore, we want to
be phase-sensitive.
We want to pick out
either the cosine omega
T, or the sine
omega T oscillation.
This is sort of,
homodyne detection.
We'll discuss it on Monday.
Any question?
OK.
Good.